Mr President there's talk of a Russian
surge coming soon
when do you think that might be and how
prepared are you
my channel
[Music]
um
War rips families apart a lot of young
Russian boys are being sent to their
deaths as cannon fodder what's your
message to their parents
president
Abram tanks are coming from the United
States and finally leopard two tanks are
coming from Europe you must be relieved
uh
um
the tanks could be here from Europe soon
but the tanks from America may take
until August is that too late
too late
but but I I I don't know really I don't
know real situation for now for this
minute when they will be when they when
America uh uh will give us Abrams and
and I don't know
I don't know really when from Europe
will come tanks
can I take you back to almost a year ago
and the start of the war
tell us what you remember about the
night that the Russians were coming how
close were they to you some suggestions
they were just two kilometers away
foreign
under what circumstances would you
consider peace negotiations
if you can't sleep at night and are
alone with your thoughts do you ever
wonder what might happen if you were in
a room alone with President Putin would
that help at all to resolve this war
pretty interesting for me
for me not interesting to meet
not interesting to speak
why because we had meeting with him in
Norman de format it was before the
full-scale invasion
I saw
the man who said one thing and then did
another is it too late now
too late not interesting who is he now
after full-scale Invasion for me he is
nobody
nobody somebody who is a somebody to you
is Boris Johnson
um would you like to see him have an
official public role as a UK Envoy to
Ukraine
Embassy he will be ambassador from
Britain in Ukraine it was pleasure
I was pleasure he's a good guy and I'm
not I'm not I'm not sure that he's ready
for such status because no but who knows
I mean that Jewish pleasure was pleasure
really how would you feel if he ran
again to be prime minister would he get
your support
I think that it's not correct to me to
support Johnson to be a prime minister
when
rishi's prime minister is not correct
I'm sorry we have good relations with
sunak I think we had
more long relations with Johnson because
it was more long time and of course
and of course very difficult time at the
first days of full-scale innovation
that's why I I saw Johnson in different
situations I saw him in not in war and
then in full-scale war that's why we
have special relations